♪♪
What's up?
We're leaving you and Mythic
Quest.
No.
Yes.
♪Work It Out,
Work It Out♪
♪Work, Work, Work It Out♪
♪Out♪
♪Work...Work♪
Have you ever spent any time in
the Metaverse?
♪♪
Oww!
That's way above my pay-grade,
pal.
♪♪
I'm just the janitor.
(Excited screeching)
I got an NFT for ya: No
(beeping) Thanks.
♪♪
Ian Elizabeth Grimm!
Is that his middle name?
IAN!
♪♪
There have been reports of
repeated harassment.
From who?
It's anonymous, David.
It's her.
That tracks.
-Yeah, that tracks.
Carol, can you tell Poppy to
stop acting like a cat?
I'm not acting like a cat, I'm
acting like (gags).
You see, Carol, these kind of
meetings did not happen when I
worked here.
We had this exact meeting.
Carol, if I may?
You may not.
Yes, okay.
♪Wor-wor-work it out♪
♪♪
It's an honor, Mr. Grimm.
I'm a huge fan.
I like this guy.
Please kill me.
Really?
♪♪